70 bougies pour l'un des chanteurs les
plus populaires de france renaud tout au
long de sa carrière l'artiste a imposé
son style musical rempli dargaud et de
verlan sur la tête je lis pas cette
chose de déblais je pourrai jamais dire
ça gérer c'est lourd toujours en 1978
l'artiste est au début d'une carrière
prometteuse à 25 ans il vient de sortir
son deuxième album laisse béton il ne
connaît pas l'anglais il parle largo le
verlan il manie l'expression populaire
avec maestria et tout un public le
comprendre les mots du dictionnaire très
peu pour lui largo c'est sa marque de
fabrique mais d'où lui vient ce langage
réponse en 1981 c'est un langage que
j'ai à brive ont déjà quand j'étais môme
et puis après quand j'ai fréquenté les
lycées les écoles j'ai un peu perdu mais
après quand j'ai arrêté mes études à 16
balles et j'ai commencé à bosser donc à
fréquenter un peu la rue il était
coursier j'étais possédant des boutiques
chauffeur-livreur comme ça j'ai commencé
à faire monter les bistrots et la rue
est jeune et puis la banlieue c'est là
ça m'a rendu fort
ce langage de la rue renaud l'utilisera
dans ses textes pendant toute sa
carrière comme dans le titre laisse
béton son premier succès sorti en 1977
l'histoire d'un loup bar dépouillés par
une autre bande de loubards j'parie
seller santiag bien faire un tour dans
un terrain vague tout apprendre un jeu
rigolo à grands coups de chaînes de vélo
je te fais tes bottes à la baston
fraîche guéri
laisse béton
autres grands cartons mistral gagnant
sorti en 1985 est lui aussi bourré
dargaud dans ce texte destiné à sa fille
renault y raconte son enfance signaux
les beaux mecs c'est du
lauquet chaîne marchands concernés
mintoh
ramel un franc
les mistral gagnant renault enchaîne les
titres et les succès à partir de la fin
des années 2000 l'artiste se fait plus
rare dans les médias 2016 après sept ans
d'absence il revient sur le devant de la
scène avec le titre toujours debout et
largo lui aussi est toujours là pour
yvan
rassurez-vous toujours la banane
toujours debout je suis retaper remis
sur pied droit sur mes guiboles
ressuscité
depuis le début de sa carrière en 1975
le chanteur a sorti 28 albums et en a
vendu plus de 20 millions au total
[Musique]